voilà une situation privée qui a tout de
même suscité quelques réactions à
l'étranger voyons comment cette
information est abordée et commentée par
les médias en grande bretagne en italie
ou encore aux états unis anne pons
signer
incontestablement pour les médias
étrangers nicolas sarkozy est un people
son élection avait suscité beaucoup
d'intérêt ces déboires privés ne laisse
pas indifférent ensuite à chacun son
regard le tabloïd britannique daily mail
administre une leçon de morale aux
couples en titrant une affaire gauloise
la télévision suisse elle traite la
faire comme une saga
c'était émouvant et un journal suédois
se demande si ce divorce n'est pas la
preuve que la france est devenue moderne
pour un journaliste de la rai c'est un
signe en tout cas que le confortement
des hommes politiques a changé si on
pense aussi aux couples ségolène royal
hollande
cette nouvelle génération d'hommes
politiques
ils mettent un peu plus ses affiches un
peu plus leur vie privée certains
journaux suisses et allemands se demande
si la réconciliation du couple était un
leurre
quant au journaliste de cnn la collusion
de l'annnonce du divorce et du jour de
grève ne lui a pas échappé
il en tire sinon des conclusions
politiques une chute ironique pour les
transports les choses devraient
s'arranger ce week-end mais on ne peut
pas en dire autant pour le mariage de
sarkozy
léger cruel voire franchement peu
élégant les correspondants étrangers à
paris ont rivalisé d'imagination avec
sans doute un peu moins de retenue que
leurs confrères français
vu de loin c'est toujours plus facile
politique